parler de ce clip révélée par la
république en marchant son compte
twitter renaissance eux dans la
perspective des élections européennes du
mois de mai et dure deux minutes
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il ne fait pas dans la dentelle je
vous propose de le constater vous même
même si on passe pas l'intégralité des
deux minutes mais quelques secondes qui
vont vous donner une impression vous
donner sur une impression assez juste de
ce clip
regardez
[Musique]
regardez notre époque regardez là en
face et vous verrez que vous n'avez pas
le choix
vous n'avez qu'un choix simple celui de
choisir de laisser un peu plus de place
à chaque élection aux nationalistes à
ceux qui détestent l'europe et dans 5
ans dans dix ans dans 15 ans ils seront
là nous les avons déjà pu gagner ici je
vous demande vous et en particulier vous
jeunesse l'europe d'avoir cette ambition
extrême peut-être un peu folle
ce que nous espérons est entre nos mains
désirons le ensemble pour nous et pour
nos enfants
alors je vous le promets nous réussirons
alors les mots de macron qu'on entend
battre d'un discours en partie d'un
discours à la sorbonne en septembre 2017
qui prouve que le président de la
république n'a pas changé de logiciel
n'est pas changé de ligne sur l'enjeu de
ce scrutin
moi ou le chaos le les progressistes
contre les nationalistes ce clip c'est
un petit peu caricatural quand même
guillaume tabard bas côtés quand on
regarde on se demande si c'est un gag si
c'est un sketch des inconnus
si c'est une parodie des opposants les
plus plus les plus noirs contre emmanuel
macron qui peut vraiment les le concret
pour le tourner en ridicule ont décidé
on va aller on va montrer quelque chose
de de caricatural à souhait voilà que
dire c'est rigolo sincèrement je me suis
posé la question je n'en mets moi ce que
c'est d'abord ce qu'on mélange beaucoup
de choses là qu'on voit des menaces des
gens casquette c'est après on voit il ya
évidemment une marche pour la vie aussi
donc il présentait comme un danger
absolument terrible pour la peau la
sécurité des peuples
on a des musiques dramatique
pour des opposants et puis on a des
visages souriant pour souligner les mots
d emmanuel macron axa majorque aussi une
captation d'héritage parce que les
images on voit mitterrand mitterrand
kohl
on voit vaclav havel a à prague on voit
la chute du mur de berlin
il me semble que toutes ces images qui
ont façonné l'histoire de l'europe
c'est un patrimoine commun et que l'on
peut être adorateurs de jean claude
juncker ou est souverainiste et avoir
vibré et pleurer la chute du mur de
berlin et donc voit donc je trouve que
c'est au mieux caricatural et même un
peu et sur le fond quand même assez
choquant de 2 mais ça correspond
exactement à la volonté des macros nice
d'installer une campagne européenne qui
soit kleven binaire cris vente binaire
et quand on veut être binaire d'iphone
caricatural et on ne l'est jamais assez
ce clip on est en ville à la valeur à
masquer le spécialiste de l'image
justement de l'image en politique qu'est
ce que ça vous a installé rue circule
alors moi j'ai évidemment on va beaucoup
on a beaucoup étudié les connais tous
les clips sont un peu ridicules tout
laisser le principe d'une certaine
manière du stéréotype c'est à dire que
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
il faut aller très très vite il faut
contrôler l'émission c'est faire que ce
que l'on dit ne soit pas mal interpréter
surinterpréter ou ou tordus et donc ça
fait ça ça oblige à être puissant fort
clair donc un peu ridicule et un peu
systématique donc c'est l'écriture du
clip qui veut ça ensuite est-ce que ce
que emmanuel macron a voulu passer dans
ce clip est bien passé je le crois
justement par rapport au problème de la
réception c'est à dire le fait de ne pas
comprendre ce sont liées non croquer
actif a été moins efficace
et puis surtout on s'est pas trompé sur
l'essence qu'il voulait donner
et là vous l'avez mille fusées rebond
bien trouver saada côté les menaces les
menaces que nous connaissons passions
tristes de l'europe
oui alors là et on est évidemment dans
du maquereau c'est un peu de
grandiloquence d'abord pourquoi est ce
que c'est encore lui qui fait le qui
fait la voix off
y'a pas d'autres personnes tout
simplement même un acteur comme on fait
dans les bons films qui auraient pu donc
en est sa masse est un acteur tout à
fait cet acteur c'est l'acteur du sud
d'abord une acteurs de la vie politique
moi je pense est un acteur plutôt delà
du spectacle donc enfin lucas peut
apporter encore une fois lui qui se met
en avant avec en portant à lui à la fois
évidemment ça à sa puissance du
président annick et en même temps toutes
les critiques qu'on peut avoir sur lui
donc je trouve qu'il est assez efficace
ce qu'il vous trouve pas moins ridicules
voyez je suis plus indulgents que vous
je le trouve clair que les internautes
du figaro qui sont choqués de 76 pour
tous les clubs auront la même eau tous
les clips auront exactement le même
jugement joue la sueur et la
particulièrement dans ce qui veut dire
c'est à dire encore une fois donc
détestons camp nou face au coût de la
menace nous détestons que l'on fasse
est ce qu'on essaie de nous faire peur
tous les français et puis je pense que
ce serait me donne donc prêt dans
d'autres peuples
on est plus intelligent que ça et ça il
nous prend un peu pour de bon secours
dès que les abaisser ok la voile a
essayé à ce côté là dans 7 mai nous
puisque nous le sommes aussi
c'est à dire que nous sommes aussi une
faute on en saura nous rappeler les
baisers du bea bas et je crois
qu'effectivement sur l'europe
il ya effectivement un monde qui est
contre l'europe et entre un monde qui
est pour et peut-être est-ce là le
nouvel vos véritables en partage direct
sont quand même assez virulente nicole
clip ridicule et scandaleux yoann c'est
une parodie donc comme vous bien bigot
expose la question est à européen ce
clip est de la propagande moralisatrice
monsieur babineau en glisser dans la
caricature amélioration nationale en
face et très souvent dans l'outrance et
la caricature tout le monde s'est
habitué
guillaume bigot entre ça et captain
europe vous savez ce personnage ans là
aussi il voulait que c'était on est
quand même loin
du débat mitterrand ses gains par
exemple est ce que l'europe ça doit se
résumer à deux experts n'empêche pas
l'autre mais en l'occurrence cherche le
départ d' équivalent au à marine le pen
près de la mer regardant alors agir le
clip est ridicule et et là il n'a même
pas le défaut de mettre en avant ses
deux complices y mc ronde plus présents
devant la mer ou devant on pourrait
rêver de la coédition dans notre pays de
clip ridicule des uns et des autres et
de débats de haut niveau comme un
guerrier à propos de maastricht
bah en fait ce n'est que pendant la
campagne il emmanuel macron s'était fait
taper sur les doigts parce que c'était
la renaissance de la france elle avait
utilisé une banque d'image américaines
qui avaient également été utilisé par
contre qu'à mcdo et c'est finalement
c'était assez raccord en réalité quand
on a révélé l'origine de ces images
étaient assez raccord là ce qui est très
étonnant quand même c'est que
l'inconscient parle très fort hurle même
parce que ça démarre par vous n'avez pas
le choix
bon alors on voit bien quand on regarde
ça on n'a pas du tout le choix c'est sûr
on va on personne ne veut du cauchemar
qui n'osaient qui nous est proposé en
pendant je trouve que ce qui est
vraiment intéressant aussi c'est sait
comment lutter contre le populisme c'est
à dire l'exaltation des instincts les
plus bas à l'exaltation de la peur la
démagogie la caricature etc
en utilisant la caricature la démagogie
les instincts les plus bas la peur et la
bêtise la bêtise et paix s'ils prennent
vraiment les gens pour des crétins fin
quand cette espèce de freluquet de
gander 10 pourrait faire passer des
tests de quotient intellectuel avant de
rentrer dans les manifestations
embaucher des gars faut être embauché
des gens qui vous font des clips est
peut-être passé les tests de qi y avons
passé quand même sidérant il n'y a pas
si vous regardez ce clip un argument il
n'y a pas un n'a remis masque d'isabelle
c'est pas fait pour c'est stupéfiant ici
à l'intérieur on avait une certaine
pression ce parce que dans l'express de
cette semaine vous fait la une ce lien
ne pas rire vous faites la une sur ce
match en regrettant d'ailleurs que le
scrutin des européennes prennent cette
direction on se dit qu en vous demandant
où sont les autres parce que si on parle
aujourd'hui de macron versus les
nationalistes
plus rarement nationale c'est qui a rien
entre les deux parce que ma croûte
semaine à tuer ce match
tous les autres matchs en tout cas pour
laisser ce seul match
non la question vous poser dans
l'express je pense qu'il y a eu
suffisamment daviau tôt cette table pour
esquinté macron donc le les prendre
avant le cliff le clip ou maquereau on
va essayer de résumer l'échiquier
politique français un donc nous avons
mélenchon qui exècre l'europe le front
national national devenu rassemblement
national qui exècre l'europe ce qui leur
reste les bribes du parti socialiste des
gens comme benoît hamon qui détestent
l'europe à gauche en europe à gauche de
mélenchon il ya des gens qui n'en ont
nourri sa cocarde européenne alors là en
tout cas qui n'est pas social et libéral
rimer monsieur wauquiez n'aime pas cette
europe là et fait une campagne qui n'est
pas pro européenne donc finalement ben
si il reste pas faire de soldes il reste
d'un seul candidat pour européens ces
macro ça c'est non ça c'est parce que si
on dit qu'en gros il ya les pro
européens d'un côté les anti européens
de l'autre les pro européens sont censés
plutôt défendre ce que l'europe a fait
depuis 60 ans ah bon or c'est
effectivement le discours qu'a voulu
installer emmanuel macron début mais
depuis notamment dans sa fameuse tribune
dans les pays européens
son slogan c'est cette europe il faut la
changer et il fait un constat d'échec
depuis une semaine à bari mais donc
sinon il y avait le compris aussi que le
regard sur l'europe était un peu plus
subtil de on est pour on est contre et
que pierre moyen de sentir européen de
la loire et faire progresser leur ont
dit qu'ils sont mal adaptés la voix
comme la voie moyenne guillaume qui est
celle de la renaissance européenne il
appelle sa maman là on a le droit de pas
aimé ce jeune homme
ce genre de grandiloquence a le droit
mais il veut dire clairement cette
europe là tel qu'un et ne fonctionne pas
bien donc il faut la réformer
bon ben moi j'ai pas appris à cette
occasion qu'il était un réformateur
j'en suis d'ailleurs plutôt réjoui qui
selon l'informateur sur le clip lui-même
moi pardon je veux désagréments pour
personne mais je je parle que pour moi
il s'adresse pas à ma génération
il s'adresse à des jeunes c'est un clip
qui est fait par des jeunes pour des
jeunes d'ailleurs il montre beaucoup de
jeunes qui n'ont pas forcément mémoriser
que la chute du mur de berlin et tous
qui a accompagné la construction de
l'europe était à m parmi les acquis
fondamentaux de l'europe
donc je pense que c'est bien de leur
ramener en 2012 et l'arrêt dans les
considère comme les contes et légendes
urbaines et je sais ce que c'est de là
qu'elle commet souvent qu'un pas non je
suis pas d'accord c'est pas des jeunes
et des enfants donc il ne vois pas
quelqu'un de 18 en garde ce clip il a
ses sens et pour moi je pense que c'est
bien de rappeler tout ce qui a été
accompli il ya à bruxelles un musée qui
représente très bien une européenne et
on a tout remonte à tous jusqu'à depuis
erasme et même au delà l'empiré romain
il faut rappeler des étapes ce clip
moi personnellement je n'aurais pas
signé mais il remet en scène de nu de
l'europe oui j'aurais pu rejoindre / / /
structure politique non mais on peut
tout prendre tout le monde prendre vous
pouvez déjà faire de se revendiquer de
tous les héritages non mais vous pouvez
pas exclure l'europe l'histoire de
l'europe de l'histoire de l'union
européenne je veux dire l'union
européenne n'est pas né elle est née
aussi des carnages l'euro résistait
avant une longue mais nettement
et si vous voulez tout savoir comme dit
le grand historien denis de rougemont
l'europe existaient avant ces nations
n'en déplaise
l'europe exige un arrêt 1c nations n'en
déplaise au souverainisme donc on met ma
voix c'est eux et bien entamé le dernier
jour aux gens sur un historique vrai que
les images de la chute du mur de berlin
du du printemps de velours et stern
arrivée sur du velours unsa ce sont des
images fortes et constitutif de leur oui
mais précisément tout ce qui s'est passé
enfin je pense que la dernière fois que
l'europe a vraiment rêver c'était dans
ces années-là zélés 89 90 autant me
rappeler oui mais rappelons-le est
rappelons-le est rappelons que tous ces
pays précisément était en dehors d'eux
non refaire et que cela s'est passé
quelque chose de rigolo si c'est aussi
cette réunification démocraties laisse
le 7 mai à l'union et à la réunification
de l'allemagne aussi quelque chose de
deuil historiquement inouïe et je pense
bouleversant elle s'est faite contre
l'avis d'un mitterrand qui lui était un
grand défenseur de la construction de
cette europe qui allait paraître peu
mais on était à 12
on n'arrête pas une hausse de 70 ans a
fait tomber le mur de berlin très peu de
temps ce un sujet un peu moins important
et un peu plus lointain c'est on passe
au dernier sujet pardon de tricot sur
les municipales de 2020 donc on se
projette un petit plus loin
avec cette multiplicité de candidatures
depuis depuis plusieurs semaines entre
les possibles les probables comme
benjamin griveaux les candidats à la
candidature comme mounir majidi ou
cédric villani pas la république en
marche ces derniers jours ont vu trois
nouveaux concurrents apparaître rachida
dati pour les républicains même s'il n'a
pas encore l'investiture officielle
pierre yves bournazel et gaspard ganzer
sans étiquette qui était d'ailleurs
l'invité de istres et art tout à l'heure
dans le toqué et qui annonce ce soir la
liste de ses colistiers à paris je vous
propose de l'écouter
les gens sont plus intéressés par les
vieille chapelle politique les vieux
partis comme le ps et les républicains
ou autres ils ont envie de mouvements
citoyens qui repartent de la base et qui
propose des idées nouvelles et c'est
pour ça qu'on a créé parisienne parisien
et qu'aujourd'hui on a trente quatre
chefs de file dans tous les handicaps
challenge dans les arrondissements de
paris 124 les deux quartiers et 1500
membres d'une table où j'ai l'impression
que anne hidalgo est menacée sachant
qu'il y a un sondage qui sort dans paris
match en sondage ifop qui il a fait
nettement remonté en côte de popularité
parce qu'elle a pris 12 points dont 14
je crois auprès des marcheurs donc un
public et n'était pas forcément un
électorat qui n'est pas forcément le
sien
elle a du souci à sion ou au contraire
cette profusion de candidature lasserre
finalement en tout cas il ya quelques
semaines on l'a donnée